i love when kim kardashian messages me
in the middle of filming a body with
buzzfeed
wow it's okay uh kim kardashian
never messaged me but she will after
this makeover she'll probably block you
after this makeover
guys these past few weeks have been
crazy i recently did a video where i
tried to get more instagram followers
and i actually ended up getting a bunch
of instagram followers
oh my god guys i got 10 000 followers
i've been having so much fun with
instagram posting stories and pictures
but i still haven't mastered it i'll
feel pretty confident in my instagram
game once i get to a million followers
and currently i have about
well over over 900 000 to go but it's
okay because i got a plan so here's what
i'm thinking most big instagrammers are
out in l.a so
i'm going to la baby so the plan was to
fly to la and get some help from james
charles who has almost 5
million followers on instagram and takes
incredible pictures i still can't
believe he agreed to do this hi sisters
i got him in the video because he slid
into my dms so wow you're supposed to be
this early on
you slid back into mine though you did
reply i thought you were that's just
like being friendly i didn't know that
was like
is this not our first date what are we
doing today
we'll need to give you a makeover why
your instagram kind of sucks what
i'm going to miami [ __ ]
my new haircut hashtag i'm sexy and i
know it i feel like i didn't
i didn't write those this feels like a
like a vine but like a really bad vine
eric come on you need to focus on
studying that's it no more breaks okay
one more snack break
all right come on come on [ __ ] now i'm
thirsty
your eyebrows are not touching anymore
which is really great
this 21 picture is really cute although
that should have been me instead of your
girlfriend but
we can let that slide this one's a
pretty decent one but once again should
have been me
i'm definitely that flexible we can do
that
i think overall your old instagram game
was horrible
but everybody's wasn't like 2013. i feel
like we definitely need a wardrobe
change
you wear a lot of v-necks like a lot of
v-necks there's like chest hair showing
in every picture
so what's the game plan i think we need
to go shopping
[Music]
[Music]
oh
so for our first official look for today
i really wanted to put eric in a night
out
fitted tailored suit type of look for
the pants you want the nice skinny fit
pair of black
dress pants for me personally i hate
slim fit pants i definitely like pants
that have a good
shape to them and these pants kind of
got a little bit more narrow at the
ankle which gives a nice shape to the
leg
and then we finish off the entire look
with a good and fresh chelsea boot we
also added a bow tie as well which i
definitely prefer over a regular
long tie i just feel like it's much much
cuter more trendy more like hipster and
more like
new york city boy on the go but the
reason james found me a new outfit in
the first place was to help me with my
instagram so he took this stylish
picture
i asked him to post it on his instagram
he didn't reply
so i posted it on my own page and i
gained
[Music]
i gained no followers literally i got no
followers
and i'm broke because i spent over 300
on the suit and a bunch of money to fly
to la and after 24 hours of chopping
with james charles i'm still wearing a
v-neck and my chest hair
is still showing you know what nobody
made it on social media after 24 hours
you got to work
you got to be persistent so i'm not
going to give up i'm going to keep
making videos until i hit a million
followers so let's go find some more
help
[Music]
let me know who you think i should reach
out to next
you